ملايين المواطنين من الموت
المحتوم ولذلك فقد قمنا باعلان
سلاحا جديدا ومريبا يستطيع حصد
العديد من الارواح البريئة
بعد? لقد كانت كارثة انسانية
بشرية شنيعة لم تحدث من قبل ولا
اذا لم تقبل اليابان بشروطنا يجب
ان يتوقع امطارا من الخراب تسقط
وتدمير فاذا استكملنا القتال
سيؤدي ذلك الى القضاء على
تلقوا صدمة قوية في هيروشيما.
ولم يكادوا يستفيقوا منها حتى
من بعد. وكانت هذه الهجمات هي
الوحيدة التي تمت باستخدام
حالات نفسية لا علاج لها. فضلا
عن التشوهات بسبب المواد
المدينة قد تم ابادتهم. يا لهذه
الكارثة الدامية. اي ظلم واجرام
اليوم المشؤوم. سكان هيروشيما
تعرضوا لابشع كارثة قد يتعرض لها
المدينة. تم اطلاق قنبلة
هيروشيما التي تدعى بالولد
هذا كله ما الذي جرى? بل يفترض
بنا ان نسأل ما الذي لم يجري
اليابانيين والحضارة الانسانية
ككل. وبالتالي كيف لنا ان نحمي
من المباني والبنى التحتية
بالتراب. وهل نستطيع السؤال بعد
بالقنابل الذرية ومحوها من
الخارطة فما الذي عملته اليابان.
بضربة واحدة. مئة واربعون الف
شخص قتلوا وتمت ابادتهم في هذه
الاسلحة في تاريخ الحروب. وبعد
القصف اعلن الرئيس ترومان قائلا
الفظائع كما تم اسرهم حتى يقوم
الجنود اليابانيون الجزاء من جنس
سمعوا الانفجار المدوي الثاني.
لقد قامت القيامة في اليابان ان
الصغير ليتلبويه واصبح مدينة
هيروشيما في خبر كان واصبح الحجر
واربعين. في هذا التاريخ المشؤوم
الذي قد مضى عليه اكثر من خمسة
انتقاما لكن النتيجة واحدة. في
عام الف وتسعمائة وخمسة واربعين
خلال التشويه الواضح لم يتم
اعفاء الاطفال الصغار من هذه
ام ان اليابان قد اخذت عبرتها من
جرائمها السابقة بحق البشر
ومع نهاية الحرب العالمية
الثانية اجتمعت امريكا وبريطانيا
الجريمة. فهل تنتقم اليابان يوما
لكارثتها التي احدثتها امريكا?
التقارير الصينية. كما ارتكبت
القوات عمليات ونهب للمدينة. حتى
الذين يتراوح عددهم بين اربعين
الف الى ثلاثمائة الف حسب
اربعمائة وعشرة الاف شخص. ارقام
مهولة ومرعبة لكن الشيء الوحيد
الحياة بدونهما. وبعد ذلك بسنوات
وقبل ان ينسى العالم تلك
عام ثمانية وثلاثين ارتكبت
اليابان واحدة من اكبر جرائم
والمؤكد هو الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية هي من قادت تلك
بقرار استسلام اليابان دون قيد
او شرط والا فسيتم قصف اليابان
كل هذه الاضرار كانت بشرية. وفي
المقابل تمت تسوية سبعين بالمائة
عشر من شهر اغسطس امبراطور
اليابان يصرح قائلا يملك العدو
بانفجار القنبلتين مات خوفا. اما
من استطاعوا النجاة فقد دخلوا في
عاصمة الصين حينها. وخلال تلك
الفترة قتل جنود الجيش
الجرائم. وخلال اقل من شهرين بين
انتهاء عام سبعة وثلاثين وابتداء
الشعب الياباني نتيجة افعال
جنوده وحكومته وان لم يكن ذلك
خصوصا وان اليابان تعتبر حاليا
اقوى الدول الصناعية في العالم
بحسب التقارير تم تنفيذ عدد كبير
من عمليات من قبل الجنود
استسلامنا. ونتيجة لقصف
القنبلتين فقد اصيب وقتل اكثر من
تم اطلاق القنبلة الاخرى. الناس
في اليابان في حالة ذهول. لقد
الكيماوية التي اصبحت امراضا
يتوارثها الاجيال جيلا بعد جيل.
مذهولون من هول ما يجري لهم. وهل
كان قليلا ما جرى لهم؟ هذه
والشجر والبشر رمادا بعد تلك
الفاجعة. وبعدها بثلاثة ايام فقط
القنبلة الثانية سقطت في وتدعى
بالرجل البدين. ومن لم يمت
سكان هيروشيما. لكن لماذا يا
ترى? السبب بسيط لان سكان هذه
عليهم من الجو لم يرها احد من
قبل على هذه الارض. وفي الثاني
البشر. ما ذلك الانفجار الضخم.
سؤال راود جميع سكان اليابان عدا
هذا. الاطفال والنساء والرجال
والشباب وكبار السن. انتهوا
وسبعين عاما. لكن اعراضه لم
تنتهي حتى هذه اللحظة. ففي هذا
طرق القتل تم تشريح اسرى الحرب
احياء بدون تخدير. وتم تجريب حقن
عن الاسرى لمعرفة المدة التي
يستطيع فيها البقاء على قيد
من عشرة الاف من اسرى الحرب
الصينيين. واسرى من الجزيرة
وكندا مؤتمر بوتستام وكان رئيس
المؤتمر هو هاري دسومان وخرج
كفئران تجارب لابحاث مجنونة
وتسببت هذه الوحدة في مقتل اكثر
الكورية ومن غوليا والاتحاد
السوفيتي عن اي اجرام نتحدث يا
في الحقيقة اليابان لم تعمل شيئا
سوى انها رفضت الاستسلام بشكل
هذه الوحدة قامت بافعال شنيعة
واستخدمت سجناء صينيين وسوفييت
قطعي. التاريخ المشئوم. السادس
من اغسطس عام الف وتسعمائة وخمسة
سادة. قتل هذا العدد هو جريمة
حرب ولكن الاكبر من ذلك هو تعدد
العمل. ليس نكاية ولا شماتة في
اليابانيين لكن هذا ما حصل
البداية قتلت النساء فور تعرضهن
تم قتلهن في كثير من الاحيان. من
وللاسف راح ضحية ذلك المدنيون من
النساء والاطفال والشيوخ وتلقى
اليابانيين ذهبوا من باب الى باب
بحثا عن النساء ليتم اسرهن في
الحلفاء جملة شهيرة. اني اقتل
الشخص ذاته اكثر من عشر مرات
وتصيبهم نوبة جنون لكثرة تدفق
السيول البشرية من اليابانيين.
قتل مائة وخمسين شخصا. اي اجرام
هذا؟ وما هذه القسوة؟ وعن اي ظلم
قاتل اليابانيون مع دول المحور
بشراسة وكانوا على ابواب النصر.
ان اثنين من الجنود اليابانيين
تنافسا على من يقتل مائة شخص
نتحدث؟ حوالي عشرين الف امرأة
صينية تعرضت اثناء الاحتلال.
صيني بالسيف فتجاوز كلاهما هذه
المرحلة فقرر زيادة المنافسة الا
الامبراطوري الياباني مدنيين
ونزعوا سلاح الجنود الصينيين
القتل الجماعي قبل القوات
اليابانية ضد سكان ناين شينج
وكان الياباني يدوس على جثة اخيه
كي يصل لعدوه. وهناك اطلق جنود
بيد العدو. وخلال المعارك كان
يصاب جنود الحلفاء بحالة نفسية
الحرب عبر التاريخ. انها مذبحة
ناين جينج التي كانت حلقة من
الاسرى بالامراض والاوبئة وتم
الحوامل. وتم منع الطعام والشراب
كانت اليابان قد اسست ما يسمى
بالوحدة سبعمائة وواحد وثلاثين.
وانتهكت حقوق البشر. عن قنبلة
هيروشيما نتحدث وللقصة بقية.
واحد. لكن قبل ذلك وبالعودة الى
عام الف وتسعمائة واثنين وثلاثين
وذلك لكثرة التشابه بين
اليابانيين كان يعتقد انهم شخص
الزمان اغسطس عام الف وتسعمائة
وخمسة واربعين. المكان في
وكان المقاتل الياباني عندما
تنفذ ذخيرته يفضل على ان اسيرا
سكان المدينة لم يسمعوا بها.
يقال اذا سمعت صوت الرصاصة فاعلم
انها لم تصبك. فما بالنا بقنبلة
برية نووية كيماوية. اي اجرام
القيت القنبلة قبل خمسة وسبعين
عاما لكن دخانها واضرارها واثرها
واعتبرت هذه بتلك.
لم تكن ذلك الحمل الوديع قبل هذه
القنبلة. فقد ارتكبت جرائم كبيرة
تتعدد الاسباب والاجرام والظلم
واحد. لكن في المقابل فاليابان
كيف ذلك? ولماذا استخدمت هذه
القنبلة? وكيف كانت ردة فعل
اليابان. ما الذي حدث يا ترى?
هناك القيت اكبر واقوى قنبلة
استخدمت خلال الحروب في التاريخ.
انها ابادة جماعية يا سادة. لكن
هذا؟ ومن ذا الذي يلقي هذه
القنبلة على مدينة اهلة بالسكان.
ما زالت متواجدة حتى هذه اللحظة
سمعت بها الدنيا باكملها لكن